we're actually in Europe when this  fourth earthquake happened and we  thought that at home Yale University  maybe we can arrange coordinated  telephone concert  one of the first things that popped into  all of the lemon quartets Minds when  this terrible earthquake and tsunami  happens was if  Kazu in and whose families were okay and  in fact my wife is still there and I'm  talking to her every day I'm much more  nervous and more worried than she is of  course the financially you know it could  help but more spiritual we wanted to  send a message  Japan has experienced many many disaster  before but this one is by far the worst  experience for the whole country and so  we wanted to send a message Japan is  going to be alright